the 2024 presidential race is turning
into a battle between Career politicians
versus unconventional candidates
President Biden is out in California for
a second day and hanging with big wig
donors and turning a blind eye to the
state's decaying liberal cities but as
top Democratic Challenger Robert F
Kennedy Jr is doing the exact opposite
he's walking the streets of San
Francisco to get a first-hand account of
the homeless crisis
we could solve the problem of
homelessness on the federal level by
providing homeless vouchers Section 8
vouchers to poor people and we ought to
be doing that is more important than
funding Wars it's more important than
funding overseas Adventures we need to
take care of Americans
and Republican Vivek ramaswamy is
following a similar Playbook he is
visiting a drug-infested part of
Philadelphia
just arriving in Kensington pulling up
on a street corner here we're already
seeing a lot of drug use on the streets
old manufacturing buildings that have
now been converted into wastelands
we're not wanting to run the leader
political party we're running the league
of country here
all right Dan I'm going to start with
you RFK has visited San Francisco
recently went down to see the Border I
think we talked about it last week how
is this style of doing things different
and compared to what Biden is doing
which is high-fiving everybody at
fundraisers so I do feel that with the
hunter Biden announcements today that
the Biden campaign is getting serious I
don't necessarily think that going to
campaign events where you're shaking
hands and doing you know basically no
rallies or anything like that is a
surprise from an incumbent president
he's got to go out there and raise a lot
of money they're a little bit behind in
fundraising so they're trying to catch
up that all makes sense to me however if
you want to make a difference and you
want to make a splash you do something
like what RFK Jr and Vivek ramaswami
have done even DeSantis went to the
Border all of this makes a ton of sense
if you're trying to one make get
attention especially in a crowded GOP
Primary but on the Republican on the
Democratic side of things this issue of
homelessness is so big and if you are
the president of the United States your
job is to make big decisions and solve
big problems you should want to do that
talking about climate change in
California might get you some money from
the tech CEOs it is not going to get you
the answers that you need to help solve
a problem that's biggest in California
but growing all across the country as I
don't even know if what RFK Jr is
suggesting would actually work does
section 8 housing vouchers to some of
these people out here is that going to
get them off the street I actually don't
know if that's the right answer I think
a lot of them have mental health
problems where that wouldn't even be
something that they could handle but
from a campaign perspective I think it
makes a lot of sense for them to get
some earned media attention plus a lot
of people are getting their news and
their information about the campaign on
their phone so those types of videos
make a lot of sense yeah Greg I saw you
shake your head with the housing voucher
concept that uh I think it's Vivek
thinks is important to resolving the
homelessness issue yeah it was uh
actually it was RFK brought it up and it
you know I I admire him I think he's the
most persuasive candidate out there but
I agree with you I I don't think
these are not families on the street I
mean if you're if anybody who spends
their time I go up Sixth Avenue every
day
you you're not going to hand these
people a voucher and they're going to
return to this happy Leave it to Beaver
stability you're talking about people
who daily reject other people's help
right yeah the drug addicts the mentally
ill the criminally deranged that are
there you hand them a voucher and if
they can't sell that for drugs they'll
hit you with it so I think that like
what would help RFK would probably be to
hook up with schellenberger Michael
schellenberger who's been on top of the
homeless situation in in California for
some time and has a lot of great uh uh
uh great ideas there I think RFK is a
very complicated intensely persuasive
person but there was some stuff on Rogan
that I felt was troubling I mean and I
think that a really good way to to
debate him would be to find out what the
difference between the claims that he
finds most important and the ones that
are somehow like recreational like he
believes in this sort of thing but you
know he starts talking about Wi-Fi
radiation that feels like a recreational
belief something to ponder like UFOs and
I would really like to as somebody that
really thinks he's really on to
something I think he needs to delineate
between some of the things that he
believes truly are happening and some
things that he's exploring in his brain
on Rogan you know Jessica Americans like
transparency and I think RFK is the
embody embodiment of transparency
because you know whether it's his going
on Rogan or just doing these little uh
videos from his phone whereas Joe Biden
is the guy who's got to read from the
teleprompter blow through a fundraiser I
mean how do you think that's going to
benefit well
with real jobs and the most important
job in the world often use a
teleprompter so past presidents ones
that you've liked and ones you didn't
like use teleprompters RFK
is not someone right now who's out
running the world he's trying to get
that job and frankly he's putting out a
lot of stuff that Greg said you know
maybe we need to know how serious are
you about Wi-Fi giving us leaky brain
um but I don't think that anyone with
even an ounce of conspiracy theory in
them should get nearer
the Oval Office and there was so much in
the Rogan interview we had the Wi-Fi
causing cancer 5G damaging your human
DNA he's someone who believes that Bill
Gates is trying to microchip all of us
as a tool of mass surveillance he thinks
chemicals in the water are turning boys
transgender and then if you think like
okay well maybe those are his
recreational beliefs
let's talk about the numbers that he
threw out about the budgets he said we
spent 16 trillion on the lockdowns not
true 8 trillion to Ukraine so far the
entire defense budget what we're going
to spend over a decade is 8 trillion the
man is pulling nonsense out of
everywhere constantly and I have no idea
what his platform is if he went back to
what he was like as an environmental
learn he said I'm the climate guy I
think that that could be a
that could resonate a lot more with
someone who believes in what the
Democratic party stands for but he's
just spouting Republican frankly like
deep web Republican GOP Q Anon whatever
it is conspiracy theories it got dams
don't fall for conspiracies
oh that pizza game right no but spending
it four years on Russian collusion and a
p-tape do you imagine what what that did
to this country yeah tore us apart yeah
okay well we should put the wi-fi is
giving you cancer no I actually brought
it back I actually brought up that point
there's a lot of argue with me about it
I brought it up jeez Jesse the Wall
Street Journal says that no one is
looking forward to 2024 election rematch
of two guys uh battled between two old
men and apparently they say uh is this
how the younger voters feel
the younger voters like watching someone
get their hands dirty and whether that
was Trump going to these hollowed-out
industrial towns in 2016 and saying that
these stupid trade deals bankrupted our
Midwest that's kind of what RFK Jr is
doing without the crowds you go to the
Border you go to San Francisco with the
homeless Trump went to East Palestine
Trump went to the Border Sanchez went to
the Border ramaswamy went to North
Philly that pays off with voters because
you can learn more from talking to a
homeless guy than you can talking to a
donor at a San Francisco fundraiser like
Joe Biden's doing Joe Biden's been to
Ukraine
other than that he drove an electric car
once he hasn't really shown the ability
of an 18-wheeler too that excuse me you
have to in order to govern in America
you have to experience America The Good
the Bad the Ugly crime homelessness
narcotics the Border these are flash
points you have to physically go there
and tap into that emotion talk to an
addict a nurse a refugee breathe that
air bring the Press Court to breathe
that same air they'll cover you
differently when you interact in a
compassionate way and maybe they'll
cover you in a different way knowing
where you've been Joe Biden is not
tapped into that kind of emotion these
other candidates are doing it and voters
respect that okay all right coming up
brand new details on the Frantic search
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now